hey guys today we're back with another
video about consistent hashing um
sorry for lying more than bill clinton
about monica lewinsky in terms of me
keeping saying that uh i'm gonna have
cassandra next but i'm afraid you guys
are gonna have to wait two more videos
longer to be introduced to my lovely
lady cassandra because uh first i gotta
talk about consistent hashing and then i
gotta talk about gossip protocols which
are probably the last two pieces of the
puzzle that are kind of prerequisites to
understanding how cassandra works i
don't really think it would be very fair
of me if i was just like oh yeah so you
know cassandra does sharding using
consistent hashing and then never bring
it up in my channel because that's like
exactly why i started this in the first
place it pisses me off that other
channels do that so
i'm going to cover this it's a really
short video and let's get through it and
then get to the next one and then do
cassandra
all right so consistent hashing what is
it
um
in situations where you have to balance
some sort of load between multiple nodes
in a cluster and in addition to
balancing that load want to generally
keep it such that the majority of the
items that have already been sent to
given nodes in the cluster stay at those
nodes when new nodes are added or
removed from the cluster consistent
hashing is the algorithm for you so i'm
going to go ahead and explain that later
in this video but what are the two cases
where we see this being useful well for
starters we've got sharding
so for example anytime you're
partitioning a data set
we want to make it such that you're not
rebalancing a ton of the keys every
single time you're adding or removing a
node because that would lead to network
congestion
and then another situation we see this
is something like a load balancer where
a load balancer is directing traffic
from clients to specific application
servers and then generally speaking we
want
the same requests or similar requests to
be going to the same servers
simply so that we can cache certain
previous api calls or database calls and
that way just have better cache
performance in general more hits as
opposed to misses
okay so let's do an overview of
consistent hashing so for starters we're
going to choose ourselves a hash
function and a hash function basically
takes any input and gives us an output
for uh for some given range and the
entire point of a hash function is
basically just a one-way function from
the output you can't really get back the
input but that's kind of irrelevant here
so for the purposes of this video let's
imagine the hash function is only going
to return the range 0 to 999 and then
i'm going to put all those outputs on a
ring so after 999 you go right back to
zero
so as you can see we have the ring below
in this image
so
let's imagine we want to add some nodes
to a cluster because we want to be able
to load balance between them or use
consistent hashing to
you know balance resources between all
of these nodes
so in order to add nodes to this cluster
all we're going to do is perhaps use a
second hash function or use even the
original with something like the node id
or just even use a randomizer and then
place it on the ring and then for
removing we would go ahead and remove it
from the ring in reality though
typically we don't just add one circle
per node to the ring but we add many
circles the reason we do this is so that
um
if you were to just add one circle over
the ring that one circle
might be in like a very unique portion
of the ring and you know
have no other nodes close to it and as a
result it would take up a significant
amount of the load and become a hot spot
so it's better to have multiple of these
like virtual nodes which are just you
know copies of the circle that we place
around the ring and that helps us to
more evenly distribute the load per node
okay so uh now as you can see um imagine
i have nodes one two and three and i'm
gonna say okay for each node we're gonna
put three copies of that node all over
the ring and now we have all these nodes
distributed hopefully relatively evenly
throughout the ring
so what are we gonna do say
we're using this for sharding and i have
the key jordan and we want to determine
where to place that key in value pair
first all i'm going to do is take the
hash of the key so in this case i'm
saying the hash of jordan is 261 so as
you can see on the ring 261 is a little
bit after that 250 marker
and then all we're going to do is move
clockwise around the ring until reaching
one of the node circles and send it to
that node so pretty simple moving
clockwise we first encounter node three
we're just going to go ahead and say now
that the key jordan is going to reside
on node three so as you can see this is
like a pretty relatively constant time
operation in terms of figuring out where
each key is going to be placed
and in addition to that it should
assuming we have the right number of say
like virtual nodes or just you know
replicated circles per node here
it'll make sure that generally speaking
the
load balance is relatively even per node
okay simple enough and then obviously if
i were to remove a node
since you're removing all of those uh
you know virtual copies of it
then in theory even the rebalancing on a
removal should be relatively even too
okay so like i said super quick video
but the summary of consistent hashing is
it's a good algorithm for distributing
load evenly amongst nodes in a cluster
and making sure that even on new
membership or exits from that cluster
that the majority of the items are
staying in the same place and only a few
of them are going to be rerouted to
other nodes
in terms of it being used in load
balancers this is a very popular
algorithm and i also discussed it a bit
in terms of partitioning and it's
especially prevalent in cassandra which
i'll be covering in a couple of videos
which is why i'm talking about it now
so yeah like i said this one's pretty
simple and it should make a decent
amount of sense but consistent hashing
is just a really good way to make sure
that you can distribute things not just
evenly but also in a way that they stay
to relatively the same spot even as the
size and members of the cluster change
okay have a good one guys